a superhero movie might seem like a
guarantee but there are plenty of
Vigilantes that never manage to recoup
their production costs
these Heroes couldn't save their own
movies at the box office
after Superman 3 Christopher Reeve felt
content with his tenure as the man of
steel and considered hanging up the cape
for good unfortunately for Reeve and
anyone who saw 1987's Superman Ford the
Quest for Peace that wasn't what he
decided to do when Superman goes to the
U.N and informs the representatives that
he intends to destroy all nuclear
weapons the Reps give him a standing
ovation rather than unite against him
but Lex Luthor isn't quite done with
Superman by attaching a strand of the
kryptonian's pair to a nuclear missile
and launching it into the sun Lex
creates nuclear man a villain who looks
like he was kicked out of a hair metal
band the budget of Superman 4 was 17
million dollars and it made less than 16
million dollars domestically by
comparison 1978's Superman made over 130
million dollars dateside Superman 2 made
108 million and even Superman 3 had a
domestic gross of nearly 60 million John
Cryer who played Lex's nephew Lenny
claimed that Superman 4 suffered from a
budget whittled to nothing and Reeve
said the same thing in his 1999
autobiography still me
no pain no gain when you take a look at
all the superhero movies that have
bombed in the past you can see a bit of
a pattern super powered comedies have
trouble breaking even that's a lesson
Damon Wayans learned the hard way with
1994's blank map Wayans is Daryl Walker
a technical genius who's completely
naive about the inner city neighborhood
he's grown up in when Mobsters murder
his grandmother Daryl uses his technical
expertise to become the laughable hero
Blankman in spite of his skill at making
useful gadgets Blankman is less Adept at
crafting a uniform using ordinary
clothes soaked in a special bulletproof
formula rather than designing a costume
from scratch eventually his brother
Kevin joins him as sidekick other guy
few people bothered to show up for blank
pants it's opening weekend gross was a
disappointing 3.7 million dollars which
made up almost half of what the movie
would ever make on the screen its
lifetime gross was less than 8 million
naturally critics were quick to mock the
film with its own title the San
Francisco Chronicle opened their 1995
review of the film's home release with
the title blank man should be warning
enough there's nothing there
slapped me around and call me Susan
when it comes to box office bombs
Shaquille O'Neal is no stranger while
his most famous film appearance is most
likely his title role in the poorly
received Genie comedy Kazam Jack took
another swing at film stardom a year
later when he was cast as John Henry
irons in steel it was an even bigger
failure than Kazam writer director
Kenneth Johnson told Vice he was against
the idea of Shaq as the lead from day
one but the studio wouldn't budget for
an actual actor still Johnson said that
the story of Steel's background appealed
to him as did the fact that the film
would bring the world one of the first
black superheroes on the big screen in a
Twist of Faith spawns Michael Jai White
would beat O'Neill to become the first
black actor to portray a major Comic
Book superhero in a film by 14 days
steel was released on August 15 1997
while spawn hit theaters on August 1st
just as Johnson predicted Jack was no
Man of Steel critics hated steel an
audiences probably would have hated it
two of if they'd bother to see it
despite a relatively small budget of 16
million dollars steel made back a little
over a tenth of that
in 1999 there was every reason to think
the superhero comedy Mystery Men would
be a hit considering the cast Ben
Stiller starred as Mr Furious a team
leader with some questionable super
credentials and he still had fans
repeating lines from the previous year's
comedy smash There's Something About
Mary Hank azeria appearing as the
cutlery wielding blue Raja was a regular
fixture on The Simpsons and the popular
sitcom bad about you Greg Kinnear made a
brief but memorable appearance as
Captain amazing and he was still riding
a high from 1997s As Good As It Gets
Jeffrey Rush still fresh on everyone's
mind from Shakespeare in Love played the
perfectly named super villain Casanova
Frankenstein with the support of Paul
Rubens as a hero who fights with
flatulence and smash mouth's All-Star on
the soundtrack what could go wrong
apparently plenty could go wrong Mystery
Men require close to 70 million dollars
to make and its lifetime gross was just
33.5 million in spite of its comedic
star power many weren't convinced Roger
Ebert wrote in his review Mystery Men
has moments of Brilliance waving their
arms to attract tension in a sea of
direct it's a long shapeless
undisciplined mess every once in a while
it generates a big laugh
we're not your classic superheroes we're
not the favorites
we're the other guys we're the guys
nobody ever bets on no one outside the
cast and crew of the specials knows
exactly how much the film costs to make
but considering that it was only
released in two U.S theaters it made a
lifetime gross of just over thirteen
thousand dollars it's safe to say that
it probably didn't make a profit future
superhero movie Legend James Gunn wrote
and starred in the film and what little
we do know about its behind the scenes
mess comes from the DVD's commentary
track Gunn admits his displeasure with
director Craig Mason for not
understanding his vision and blames Rob
Lowe for supposedly trashing the film he
also got into a fist fight with Jamie
Kennedy outside an Astro Burger
well the specials is seemingly a
superhero movie there's no action no
adventure and no stunning special
effects instead the film is meant to be
something of a mockumentary following
the members of a d-list superhero team
on their day off the few reviews that
the specials received weren't blowing
Nikki transfer of Pop matters wrote the
film is like a Saturday Night Live
sketch with most of the actors
completely overdoing every scene
Selena Kyle the Catwoman of the comics
and most of the movies would probably
admit that when it comes to robbing the
rich of Gotham City she does it more for
the thrill than for the money that's a
good thing considering that the stinker
of a movie bearing her superhero name
lost 20 million dollars Catwoman
deserves its honored spot on any
sensible worst superhero movie list you
could find and even many of the people
who made it agreed including star Halle
Berry herself who called it god-awful
with a lead character named patience
Phillips instead of Selena Kyle a
setting nowhere near Gotham City the
presence of magical cat powers and not a
single whiff of Batman it doesn't seem
like the writers bothered to read any of
the comics countless critics would
rather clean out litter boxes with their
own toothbrushes than watch Catwoman
again exciting horrible Direction a
confused screenplay and of course
Barry's ridiculous outfit This Disaster
of a costume was designed by Angus
strathy who earned an Academy Award for
his work on Moulin Rouge a few years
previous
he didn't win anything for Catwoman
Zoom star's Tim Allen as Captain Zoom a
washed out superhero bitter about the
loss of his powers to his team-mate
turned Nemesis concussion when scientist
Dr Grant discovers concussion is
returning to threaten the world he
recruits the former Captain Zoom to
train a new batch of pubescent recruits
based on the 2005 children's book
Amazing Adventures from zoom's Academy
Zoom tried to ride the coattails of the
budding success of superhero action
flicks more specifically it was likely
trying to share The Spoils of the
previous years Sky High which featured
teenage heroes in a school made
especially for young super people unlike
Sky High though Zoom forgot to make
money its 75 million dollar budget
returned a 12.5 million lifetime gross
and according to most of the people who
actually did see it it deserved its huge
loss the critical consensus for Zoom was
that it was boring Bland lazy and
non-original as the New York Times wrote
two infantile for tweens and two
stagnant for Tots Zoom bleed boredom
from every frame
going straight from making comic books
to movies is a big leap but if there was
ever anyone who seemed up for the task
it was Frank Miller Miller's work on the
page had been adapted into several hit
movies Sin City in 300 were based on his
work and his classic graphic novels
Batman The Dark Knight Returns and year
one were given life through animation
Christopher Nolan's Batman Begins was
heavily influenced by Miller's work and
Netflix's Daredevil definitely wouldn't
exist without it Miller directed a film
on his own for the first and only time
when he adapted the spirit a comic
written by his friend will Eisner
unfortunately the story of a cop who
rises from the grave to fight Injustice
and defend his City had critics and
audiences agreeing that Miller should
have stayed in his comfort zone
I'm gonna kill you all kinds of dead I
had you beat like eggs like you did
variety estimated that the film's poor
showing at the box office represented
tens of millions of dollars in losses
but rather than become a cult classic
the spirit has mostly been forgotten
there are some actors that you might
think were born to play superheroes but
Rayne Wilson probably isn't one of them
the man who brought Dwight troop to life
in the office is no Chris Evans or Henry
Cavill but James Gunn saw potential for
greatness when he cast Wilson as mild
manner to Frank Darbo in 2010's super
Frank is a lonely short-ordered cook
whose sanity takes a hard left turn when
his wife Sarah leaves him for a criminal
strip club owner inspired in part by a
Christian TV personality who calls
himself the holy Avenger Frank grabs a
monkey wrench and becomes the Crimson
bold he'll beat you half to death if
you're a sexual predator or if you've
cut in line at a theater
crime
Crimson bolt
a crime
critics didn't hate super but they sure
didn't love it most felt that the film
didn't really know what kind of movie it
wanted to be or what it was trying to
say super was an independent film that
was never meant to set the world on fire
and never expected to but it didn't even
manage to earn back its meager 2.5
million dollar budget in fact it never
even crossed the 1 million mark
the 2005 version of Fantastic Four and
its 2007 sequel are far from perfect
film but the 2015 reboot makes the
originals seem like The Godfather Parts
1 and 2. director Josh tranx poorly
received origin story actually did make
money when it went overseas but it did
horribly in the states with a 120
million dollar budget Fantastic Four
breakdown a little over 25.5 million on
opening weekend and scraped together a
total of 56 million before U.S theaters
had seen enough rather than a fully
developed superhero action film with an
engaging Story the movie that some call
fan forstick didn't live up to its name
as the Hollywood reporters Todd McCarthy
opened his review Fantastic Four feels
like a 100 minute trailer for a movie
that never happens as one horrible
review after another rolled in tranq
tweeted that his version of the film had
been altered by Fox however unnamed
sources from the film's production told
thr that trank was erratic and isolated
giving the studio little choice but to
step in producers Simon kinberg and
Hutch Parker took the reins at the 11th
Hour just three months before opening to
make sure there was actually something
to put on the screen
rebooting Hellboy after the enormously
popular Guillermo del Toro films was
always going to be a difficult task but
the 2019 take on the Beloved comic was
even more disappointing than skeptical
film goers anticipated this version of
the character was reimagined as a
wannabe Deadpool who engages in lots of
monstrosity cheap looking fight scenes
and makes even worse jokes monster pal
you look in the mirror recently Scarface
but meant to be humor maybe my therapist
does say that I rely on jokes as a way
to normalize unsurprisingly audiences
weren't very interested in a take on
Hellboy that had such an off-putting
Vibe released just two weeks before
Avengers end game redefined the level of
success superhero movies could
experience at the box office the 2019
Hellboy only grossed 21.9 million at the
domestic box office and accumulated a
pitiful 33 million overseas considering
it was made on a 50 million dollar
budget the 2019 Hellboy was a
catastrophic failure it's no surprise
why the David Harbor LED film did so
much worse than the two starring Ron
Perlman it just wasn't doing anything
particularly unique or entertaining it
didn't help that reviews were absolutely
atrocious which only hammered home a
toxic reception it was never going to be
easy to do a Hellboy reboot but few
could have ever imagined it going as
poorly as it did in 2019
the original X-Men in 2000 broke new box
office ground by becoming the first ever
Marvel movie to exceed 100 million
dollars at the domestic box office it
was a significant achievement that
signaled how popular superhero movies
could and would become with the general
public nearly two decades later X-Men
dark Phoenix brought the big screen Saga
to a close with a box office flop that
became the stuff of Legend while X-Men
showed just how huge Marvel movies could
be dark Phoenix demonstrated that even
projects featuring well-known Marvel
heroes and tank at the box office dark
Phoenix grossed only
252.4 million dollars worldwide on a 200
million dollar budget with just 65.8
million of it coming from North America
that was a haul roughly on par with a
domestic opening weekend of X-Men
apocalypse from just three years earlier
it was also the first time that a proper
X-Men film made under 100 million
dollars at the domestic box office while
cheaper R-rated flicks like Deadpool and
Logan ran circles around dark Phoenix
with these dismal box office numbers it
was abundantly clear that the end had
arrived for the X-Men Saga with once a
mighty big screen franchise going down
in flames
in March 2020 movie theaters around the
world shut down in response to the
covid-19 pandemic as soon as they closed
their doors speculation about when these
locations would reopen began similarly
rampant were rumors about what Motion
Pictures would usher in the reopening of
the big screen experience in the wake of
this Health crisis in August 2020 brand
new theatrical releases began to trickle
into movie theaters but they were far
from the Blockbuster Titans that
dominated the box office in pre-pandemic
times one of the motion pictures that
dove into the treacherous world of covet
era moviegoing was the New Mutants which
screened in late August 2020 after
languishing in development Health given
that there were a limited number of
movie theaters even opened in North
America at the time the New Mutants
cratered at the box office with just a
little over 49 million dollars worldwide
on a 67 million dollar budget it made
nowhere near enough globally to turn a
profit and came in Far Below any other
X-Men project even without the presence
of 19 though it was always going to be a
challenge for the New Mutants to attract
audiences with its unusual mix of horror
movie scares and superhero movie antics
oh
I'll see you in hell
under normal circumstances a sequel to
the 2017 film Wonder Woman would have
been a box office Juggernaut to be
reckoned with grossing just over 817
million dollars worldwide on a 150
million dollar budget Wonder Woman was
an incredibly lucrative Enterprise that
also Drew an enormous amount of positive
Goodwill from the general public people
were clamoring for more Diana Prince but
the sequel arrived in theaters on
Christmas Day 2020 at a time when the
covid-19 pandemic had shut down a
significant number of multiplexes in
North America it also had HBO Max on the
same day it was released in theaters a
move that shattered its box office
potential unsurprisingly the 200 million
dollar budgeted Wonder Woman 1984 was a
box office non-starter making just 169
million worldwide it especially suffered
in domestic markets where it grossed
only 46.8 million less than half the
amount that the first Wonder Woman film
made during its opening weekend will
never know how much the promise of
seeing Wonder Woman duke it out with
Pedro Pascal's Maxwell Lord and Kristen
Wiggs cheetah would have attracted
people to Cinemas if there had never
been a pandemic
in the history of superhero movie box
office bombs it's typical to see the
biggest money losers also be critically
Savaged projects that have minimal fan
bases the likes of dark Phoenix and
2015's Fantastic Four are not titles
that people like even ironically they're
just big budget disasters to devoid of
creativity to Garner significant
followings that makes the box office
trajectory of The Suicide Squad a
curious one critics were generally over
the moon about James Gunn's inaugural
directorial effort in the realm of DC
Comics adaptations but the movie itself
was one of 2021's most sizable misfires
at the box office costing a staggering
185 million dollars to realize the
suicide squad took in only 168 million
dollars worldwide a dismal amount that
included a paltry 55.8 million from
domestic territories the decision to
release the suicide squad simultaneously
in theaters and on HBO Max did it no
favors but there is more going on here
than just botched release strategy the
marketing campaign was generic and
somewhat confusing nobody was exactly
sure if it was a sequel or a reboot and
a restrictive R rating kept some younger
fans from seeing the film on the big
screen positive reviews couldn't prevent
The Suicide Squad from becoming a costly
box office stud
we're all gonna die
I hope so
grossing over 367 million dollars on a
100 million dollar budget the original
Shazam was a very profitable project
that showed the value of investing in
mid-budget superhero Fair a sequel was
inevitable especially with the dense
mythology of supporting players and
villains from Decades of Shazam comics
however many factors including the
covid-19 pandemic led to Shazam Fury of
the Gods arriving a whopping four years
after its predecessor first hit theaters
by this time the superhero movie
landscape had changed drastically and
the buzz of the original Shazam had long
vanished during its box office run
Shazam Fury of the Gods only grossed
133.8 million worldwide with just 57.6
million domestic it was a disastrous
Hall especially given the Project's 125
million dollar budget in North America
the entirety of Fury of the Gods just
barely outgrowsed the domestic opening
weekend of the original Shazam waiting
so long to deliver a sequel didn't help
Fury of the Gods and an awkward March
2023 release date only made matters
worse don't expect to see Zachary Levi
put the red and yellow outfit back on
anytime soon
in August 2022 Warner Brothers Discovery
CEO David zazlov publicly stated that
the flash was one of the best DC movies
that Warner Brothers had on its near
future release DACA so began a lengthy
publicity Blitz were Warner Brothers
execs hyped up the flash as being a
can't miss movie event something that
was going to change superhero films
forever while this may have seemed like
a smart way to drum up Buzz for a
tormented project it only succeeded in
creating a puzzling Aura around the
flash here was a movie where all the
positive publicity seemed to be coming
from Executives with a vested financial
interest in its success despite the best
efforts of WB The Flash bombed hard at
the box office the whole Affair cost at
least 200 million dollars to make not
counting the barrage of advertising and
it became clear pretty quickly that the
film was beyond rescue The Flash made
approximately 55 million dollars during
its first three days and things only
went downhill fast after that whether it
was a general sense of superhero fatigue
or a response to the controversy
surrounding star Ezra Miller The Flash
simply failed to hit the ground running
foreign